dans ce désordre politique le général
napoléon bonaparte prend les pleins
pouvoir par un coup d'état qui instaure
le consulat
contre attaque la coalition anti
françaises hélas pas
acclamée pour ses victoires éclatantes
napoléon est alors couronné empereur des
français
c'est le premier empire
napoléon continue ses conquêtes
et bah la prusse permettant plat la
pologne de se recréer
puis zidane ex des pays bas
oui
la suisse et l'italie mais enfin aux
dernières entités autonomes
enfin ils parlaient espagnol et installe
son frère joseph comme roi d'espagne
apprenant que la russie avait annexé la
finlande et la roumanie et qu'elle
prépare l invasion de la pologne
napoléon attaque aussi la russie mais il
ne trouve que des terres brûlées par ces
mêmes russes et sans ressources
alimentaires les troupes françaises
doivent se retirer
de surcroît les français sont chassés
d'espagne
et napoléon et battu à les figues par la
coalition anti françaises
il est alors contraint à l'exil mais il
s'échappe
il regroupe ses anciennes armée et
réattaque la coalition définitivement
battu à waterloo
il meurt prisonniers à l'île de sainte
hélène
c'est la fin du premier empire au
congrès de vienne les nations occupé
récupèrent leurs anciens territoires les
pays bas la belgique et le luxembourg se
déclare indépendant
en france la monarchie revient avec
louis xviii qui sera sage et prudent
mais son successeur charles 10 veut un
retour radical au passé restaure la
monarchie absolue et attaque l'algérie
et tandis que la grèce se libèrent des
turcs en instaurant la monarchie et que
la pologne airs partagé entre la prusse
et la russie en france le tiers état se
rebellent encore charles 10 doit
appliquer et c'est louis philippe
d'orléans qui lui succède
sous son règne la côte d'ivoire
la polynésie et l'algérie sont conquises
avec le soutien de la haute bourgeoisie
libérale l'industrialisation de la
france commence
mais la corruption la crise économique
et l'exploitation des ouvriers provoque
des contestations louis-philippe les
répriment alors si cruellement lui fait
éclater d'une dernière et décisive
révolution la monarchie française est
alors effacé et la seconde république
française est déclaré son président m
louis napoléon bonaparte le neveu de
napoléon
mais son pouvoir partager avec
l'assemblée nationale est limité alors
par un coup d'état
louis napoléon prend les pleins pouvoirs
et se déclare empereur de france sous le
nom de napoléon iii
c'est le second empire
napoléon iii signe avec le royaume uni
un traité de libre échange commercial et
aide le nez sans royaume d'italie de
victor emmanuel 2 en obtenant en échange
nice et la savoie
mais quand ils exigent des compensations
territoriales en échange de sa
neutralité lors de la guerre entre la
prusse et l'autriche
le roi de prusse guillaume premier qui
avait battu l'autriche et en lempire
d'allemagne refuse alors napoléon iii
lui déclare la guerre mais il est battu
et doit même cédé l'alsace et la
lorraine à l'allemagne
l' empire aboli
la troisième république française est
alors proclamé la paix avec l'allemagne
est signé et un protectorat sur la
tunisie est établi finalement les
innovations culturelles les
divertissements populaires et des
nouvelles formes d'art françaises
peuvent s'exprimer
c'est la belle époque à l'exposition
universelle de paris la tour eiffel
symbole de la france moderne est
inauguré
cependant une grande guerre se prépare
la roumanie a pris son indépendance
vis-à-vis de la russie
mais la serbie et la bulgarie
après avoir chassé les turcs se
déclarent la guerre se disputant la
macédoine
ce format alors deux coalitions la
serbie a lié à la russie à la roumanie à
la grèce au portugal au royaume uni à la
france et à l'italie contre la bulgarie
allié à l'autriche à l'allemagne et à la
turquie
seule la première guerre mondiale
l'allemagne
comment ces hostilités elle envahit la
belgique et le luxembourg
arrivant près de paris mais soudain tout
change
l'autriche sort de la nuit une défaite
militaire et une révolution ayant aboli
sa monarchie
la première république autrichienne est
proclamée une révolution éclate aussi en
allemagne
l'empereur est obligé d'abdiquer et la
première république allemande coupé en
deux entités territoriales est proclamé
c'est la fin de la guerre
la république française récupère
l'alsace et la lorraine la serbie
devient royaume de yougoslavie en russie
une révolution élimine le dard et
l'union et république soviétique est
proclamé ce qui permet à la pologne de
renaître
tout comme la hongrie et la
tchécoslovaquie au royaume-uni l'irlande
prend son indépendance
dans toute l'europe des coups d'état
militaires installe des dictateurs en
espagne le général franco prend le
pouvoir
au portugal une dictature militaire
interdit le parti communiste en italie
mussolini établi la dictature fasciste
en allemagne hitler élimine toute
opposition et se proclame fureur la
seconde guerre mondiale éclate
l'allemagne nazie
intègre une autriche pire elle envahit
la tchécoslovaquie la pologne la
belgique les pays bas le luxembourg et
même la france
l'occupant en grande partie il ne reste
de libre que la france de vichy confié
au maréchal pétain un collaborationniste
avec les nazis
tout était le nouveau perdue la france
devenait allemande
mais la résistance se prépare le général
charles de gaulle depuis radio londres
se déclare chef légitime du gouvernement
français en exil et appelle les français
au sentiment national
l'armée libre de france se constitue
alors et plusieurs unités navales et
aériennes
la rejoignent cela provoque la
répression de pétain et l'occupation de
la france entière par les nazis hitler
entre temps alliée à l'italie et au
japon a envahi la totalité de l'europe
est attaqué l'immense union solide mais
il est battu par les communistes de
staline qui avance établissant leur
régime sur les pays assujettis pour les
nazis c'est la déroute
car les armées alliées du royaume uni et
les etats unis
et du canada ont débarqué en italie et
en normandie est jointe 26 mille hommes
du général de gaulle elle libère la
france
iter ordonne alors la destruction des
ponts de paris
mais heureusement avant de s'enfuir le
gouverneur allemand refuse et le général
de gaulle
acclamé par la foule peut rentrer dans
paris
intact l'allemagne capitule et quand les
américains lancent la bombe atomique sur
le japon allié aux nazis les conflits ne
cessent définitivement c'est la paix
l'union soviétique absorbe la tchéquie
la france proclame sa quatrième
république
et l'allemagne est divisé en deux mais
l'europe aussi est divisée
le traité de yalta entre les deux
puissances victorieuses les états unis
et la russie a partagé l'europe en deux
blocs opposés dans le bloc occidental
sous l'influencé américaine certains
pays signent l'accord de l'otan pour se
protéger contre d'éventuelles agressions
soviétique dans le bloc oriental soul
influence soviétique
certains pays signent le pacte de
varsovie pour se protéger des américains
c'est la guerre froide
l'europe cependant en a assez des
conflits
ces nations sont à une solution qui les
mettrait à l'abri de nouvelles guerres
le ministre français schumann a alors
l'idée de mettre les industries liées
aux armements sous le contrôle
réciproque des deux principaux
producteurs de fer et de charbon
la france et l'allemagne et au traité de
rome la communauté économique européenne
est créé
son but est le rapprochement économique
et la libre circulation des personnes
des marchandises des services et des
capitaux entre les pays membres
les signataires en sont la france
l'italie l'allemagne de l'ouest
la belgique le luxembourg et les pays
bas
la france entre-temps a perdu plusieurs
de ses colonies
c'est le général de gaulle qui est alors
chargé de redresser le sort du pays
nommé président de la cinquième
république française de gaulle demande
aussitôt au royaume uni et aux etats
unis
le partage du commandement de l'otan
mais il refuse
alors de gaulle retire la france de
l'otan expulse les installations d'armes
nucléaires américaines du territoire
français est muni la france de l'arme
atomique n'a rendant première puissance
militaire nucléaire d'europe dans le
bloc occidental
la communauté économique européenne
s'élargir avec l'adhésion de l'irlande
du royaume uni du danemark de la grèce
du portugal et de l'espagne
elle devient l'union européenne
un changement politique met fin au
régime communiste de l'union soviétique
les pays sous son emprise reprennent
leur indépendance et l'allemagne à bas
le mur de berlin se réunit fientes en un
seul pays
avec l'adhésion de la finlande
l'autriche la suède l'estonie la
lettonie la lituanie la pologne la
tchéquie la slovaquie la hongrie la
slovénie malte chypre et enfin de la
roumanie et de la bulgarie
l'union européenne s'élargir encore et
devient l'actuel europe des 27
nous en sommes donc maintenant à nos
jours la france cinquième puissance
économique mondiale conserve des
territoires d'outre-mer elle a réintégré
l'otan pour soutenir la coopération
entre tous les pays du monde elle
participe à la guerre du golfe contre
l'irak à l'indépendance du kosovo et en
voit même des troupes en afghanistan
pour lutter contre le régime taliban
cependant elle refuse de rejoindre la
coalition pour l'occupation de l'irak
mais elle participe à l'intervention en
libye au sein de l'otan
voilà donc la grande histoire de la
france le pays le plus ancien de l'union
européenne sur sa terre millénaire les
premiers chef-d'oeuvre de l'homme sont
apparus sous son influence des grandes
nations comme l'allemagne le royaume uni
et l'italie sont nés grâce à sa culture
le monde a connu le sens de la liberté
de l'égalité et de l'art de vivre
français